[Music] I think the role that I have helped
bring to this space is bringing people together
and so I think through my work at Posit I saw
that so many of these pharmaceutical companies
just wanted to get together. They wanted to talk
and they were coming to me to say can you make
these introductions so starting R and Pharma
was really the spark that brought a lot of the
pharmaceutical companies together and there
for the first time the R validation hub had
their hangout, uh you know ideas around the pharmaverse were sparked out of the idea that these
pharmaceutical companies had specific workflows
and code that they wanted to share, so it's been
amazing to really just see the life that has
come out of the R and Pharma conference. There
was very much this sense and momentum that a new
horizon was coming out for open source to change
the landscape and lead to a lot of innovations
for clinical trials, and so a lot of groups that
had implemented R for research or for Shiny had
now started saying can we use this in addition
for our late stage clinical trials work. I could
certainly feel that there was a change coming
to the way that clinical trials were conducted
in bringing open source to that ecosystem but
I knew that it was going to take some time and
there was going to be a decent amount of change
management that would have to take place for
that to work. Part of the popularity of R in
the drug development space, especially late stage
clinical trials, is because there was a legacy stat
programming language that people had used and so
migrating from that language to R was a very easy
transition for a lot of organizations because R
is an open source language built for statistical
computing, as well as that legacy code and
programming tool was also built for stats
programming, so I think the transition from that
previous tool to R is natural because languages
like Python are more general purpose programming
languages and so I think that has led to a lot
of the adoption in the space as well as Shiny I
would say. A lot of pharmaceutical companies use
our professional software for their clinical
trials and that typically consists of Posit
Team and Posit Team is made up of three different
products - there's a Posit Workbench which is the
development environment, literally it's called a
development environment because it's where people
are going to go in and do their programming. There
they create software and artifacts and content and
Shiny apps and workflows, and then they move that
into production, into our second product which is
called Posit Connect, that's the production and
deployment platform that we host and maintain,
and then the back end, what's surfacing out the
production, and oftentimes validated packages,
for both of those environments is the Posit
Package Manager, and so that's feeding packages
for reproducibility into the development side, as
well as feeding packages into the production side.
Pharmaceutical companies care a lot about Posit
Package Manager because there is this great desire
to own and manage the validation and oftentimes
what's referred to as qualification of packages,
and so a lot of work goes internally at
pharmaceutical companies to say these are
the core packages, typically around 100 to
2 or 300 or so packages, that this is what
people are going to use for clinical trials,
so package manager specifically is critical
for clinical development because it makes the
source of where their package is coming from
locked down and approved for the work internally
at the company. Yeah, there's a lot of use cases
and companies and pharmaceutical organizations
using our professional tools. Recently this was
highlighted by Satish Murthy in the data science
hangout that they use Posit Package Manager
for surfacing and managing the source of their
validated packages that they bring out - that's
one of the most key things for organizations
is to make sure the source of the package is
coming into the workflows is validated and the
right packages. In addition to that, Merck also
had a webinar with us that highlighted their
use of Package Manager. There's lots of other
organizations that have highlighted the use of
Posit Connect for where they manage and host
their Shiny applications, for example Roche and
Genentech in their webinar a couple months ago,
highlighted that they have an entire framework
that they've built in-house around Shiny, and
they host their Shiny apps there with Posit
Connect. It's going to be interesting to see
how the future plays out with introductions to new
tooling like Python and leading that into AI, and
how some of that could change some of the clinical
trials. I don't think that's going to happen right
away but we see this very big inclusive and
interoperable future for drug development
[Music]